okay so our next guest uh zailla
avant-garde made history when she won
the 2021 Scripps National Spelling Bee
at 14 years old let's take a look at the
incredible winning moment broadcast on
ESPN
Maria
does this word contain like the English
name Murray which gives you the name of
a comedian I like to say English name
and Jennifer I don't see that here Bill
Murray made the spelling bee
Maria
that tells you she's on the right track
though wait uh what does something
Georgian it's formed in Latin from a
Swedish name
Maria m-u-r-r-a-y-a
that is correct
look at that look at that zyla was the
first African-American script spelling
bee winner she also holds two two
Guinness World Records one for the most
bounce juggles in one minute with four
basketballs and one for the most
basketballs dribbled at once by one
person she was named 2021 Sports kid of
the Year by Sports Illustrated Kids now
just 16 years old she's the author of
the new book it's called it's not
bragging if it's true how to be awesome
at Life the book includes zaila's top
nine tips for Success good morning how
are you doing I'm doing good how are you
I'm good thank you for joining us now
this book is full of great advice what
do you hope readers take away from it
they can do it like I know it sounds a
little cheesy but like if you're trying
to be a rugby player out there you can
do it if you're trying to I don't know
make curtains you can do it right like
that's my greatest Hope just that they
can take away a message of empowerment
for my book and that's not cheesy at all
you're spot on now for some kids they
might look at you and see what you have
accomplished how talented you are and
they're sitting back saying you know
what I'm just not as smart as skilled as
her what advice do you give to them you
are as smart and you can very easily
become as skilled or more skilled than
me okay let me not to say easily it's
very hard it's a lot of hard work but
it's easy to do the hard work because
it's fun so I would just say stop
thinking like that immediately because
you are just as smart as me I had so
much fun reading and you say wait a
minute remember what I said or this is
how I'm gonna say it you you have such a
realness to your writing and you also
have great great ideas for for getting
kids involved in the book The Tips
one that I really love is ask for help
not everybody does that well and you
yourself admit you aren't so great at it
yeah I'm still not great at it when I in
my book when I talked about asking for
help I kind of told the story of how
like when I was studying for 2021
Scripps National Spelling Bee my
internet wasn't working bad and let me
just say Verizon I love you
but I'm gonna call you out here my
internet wasn't working
like my dad came over and like saw that
I was struggling the internet wasn't
working and he was like why didn't you
ask me for help and he immediately just
came in and solved it by bringing in a
second computer and when he did that the
amount of words I was able to study just
skyrocketed I think Verizon's thinking
right now you know it wasn't the
internet right it was the computer all
right don't blame us uh and on that
subject actually one of the other tips
in the book is that you should pick your
opponent and Define winning what do you
mean by that I would say that like just
I just mean like know what you're going
for like sometimes you might find
yourself doing something but like you
don't have a really like a purpose when
you're doing it and trust me doing stuff
without a purpose is a really bad idea
at least for me personally because like
if I don't know like I'm trying to get
there then I'll just be lost and I won't
do it nearly as well as if I like find a
purpose and then follow that you also
say have somebody else's back what do
you mean by that well I personally am
the oldest sibling and a four I have
three younger brothers so that means I
do a lot of looking after my little
brothers and stuff including my
four-year-old brother who is a
four-year-old
we get it
um you know we have those basketballs
right there and if you would indulge us
we would love to see you show off your
skills because we talked about those
Guinness World Records
um and if you can show us
show us how to do it so is this this is
the four basketball
dribbling juggle is that is that
described correctly uh I will describe
it more as a four ball Masterpiece but
okay here we go here we go now how did
you learn how to do this and can you
talk and dribble at the same time no
y'all not about to embarrass me on
National excuses
[Applause]
amazing absolutely amazing now before we
let you go I do want to talk about the
inclusivity of the spelling bee you're
the first African-American to win and
it's almost 100 Year history how do we
make that more exclusive inclusive
excuse me I
hey can I get some tutoring like the the
rates are really high for that like to
get the tutoring and to get the programs
to work on spelling like it takes a lot
so I would just say maybe kind of lower
the price bar maybe extinguish the price
bar but I would say that would
definitely help with inclusivity you are
absolutely awesome English the barriers
thank you so much it's not bragging if
it's true goes on sale tomorrow wherever
you buy your books